ha pasado Ya casi una semana Y todavía
no hay ninguna indicio de que el
gobierno vaya a dar un resultado a esa
investigación ellos siguen insistiendo a
que maxa abría sufrido un ataque al
corazón pero su familia sigue dando
declaraciones de que tenía perfecta
salud y también las argumentan que
vieron su cuerpo y que se veía bruces
como si lo hubieran atacado y pegado
algo que niegan las autoridades y esto
crea a un mayor indignación dentro de la
sociedad que sigue expandiendo esas
protestas en diferentes partes de Irán
en ciudades remotas pero también en Irán
ya nos enteran Perdón no solamente están
en el corazón de la ciudad sino que
hacen expandido en diferentes puntos y
cada vez más violentas en la medida que
las fuerzas de la seguridad atacan con
mayor insistencia y tratan de
reprimirlos más estos jóvenes responden
con mayor agresión muchas veces hemos
visto como han atacado coches de la
policía motocicletas
prende en fuego en la calle para
defenderse y se hablan de varios muertos
la cifra no está determinada Pero entre
ellos habría un policía y dos
paramilitares llamados de esas fuerzas
llamadas en diferentes partes del país
esto sucede cuando Irán cortó el
internet el internet móvil y algunas
aplicaciones como WhatsApp trabajan
intermitentemente para tratar de
desconectar a esos que se manifiestan en
las calles hasta el momento sin ningún
éxito sin embargo se cree que la
represión será mayor en las últimas
horas Los guardianes revolucionarios han
dicho que todo aquel que protesta hace
parte de una sedición